all right let's look at the Earth hand
first okay so you're grounding he's
pushing push push push you're on that
foot
okay this hand you're going to make that
elbow go in and
forward so it's not that you're getting
out of the way and then he falls into it
he could he could be pulling pull pull
pull he could be pulling it doesn't
matter you ground and you make him go
p
it doesn't matter his grip either you
you have to use his grip use his
grip but even though his fingers are
there you don't use them you use his
grip
his two things you're looking for not
only that he goes forward but the other
one is that his elbow comes in
so you watch his elbow elbow comes
in elbow comes
in you're not going to pull it slow down
you're not going to pull
it by doing your outward
spiral this
movement you're going to get on the
other side of the
grip you see my elbows on the other side
the
grip your elbow doesn't stay on this
side of the
grip elbow
in okay let's try that arm the Earth
hand okay the heaven hand
Earth heav nope can't okay so it has to
have same thing if if he's pulling me
that way pull pull pull it doesn't
matter I should still be able to move
it it's not that you're
just opening and then he walked forward
because he's finally displacing okay
you're seizing the
center right the beginning you have a
center and you're going to compress push
that Center and then you're going to
move the
center same thing on the other hand okay
to compress you're you're in the center
and you move the
center no movement yet P
move and just as this is the earth hand
is your outward
spiral Heaven hand is your inward spiral
change your feet heav hand is your
inward
spine
feel and move his Center boom seize
it so inside his grip you have to adhere
adhere and move his body
okay all
right inside the middle of your
Ascension Center Crest which is ated
Parker's Crest which was my Kempo
teacher there's a heart
shape your inward
spiral is making that heart shape on the
outside so if I have my hand at the
bottom and I do my emmer spiral it's
making that hard shape on one side side
then the other hand would make it on the
other your outward
spiral is making it on the
inside here so if I have my right hand
I'm on the inside my left hand I'm on
this side can you guys see that
okay you have a couple things here you
have Heaven the throw is called Heaven
and Earth
throw
you have your heart pattern which is a
universal pattern and it's made of your
Inward and outward
Spirals and these are given
Elemental values
too
and
directions and
characteristics light and heavy
okay and this makes teni
nag a kind
of all encapsulating technique so for
example in the o
Sakai where I trained for most of my
time they didn't do kokun nag at the end
they did teni Naga at then okay but if
you pay attention to coku Naga it's just
teni n when you understand it this way
it's just
moved right from around the neck to in
front of the neck okay but if you pay
attention every single technique is
actually doing doing this so suos which
we did last week is doing the same thing
but it's on the wrist and elbow as
opposed to the neck and wrist
okay so now you're going to do both we
won't do any movement okay I do
[Music]
both connect
move
if you fall you fall but I'm not trying
to throw him seizing his
Center making his
Center come
forward
okay try it so now if you reverse
engineer the throw you know you have a
back breake ball the back breake fall is
going to always only be utilized when
the guys coming forward you you can't do
back break Falls you can't do a
technique that's going to throw someone
backwards that is already going
backwards um meaning if I'm here like
this you uh and you just come forward to
do the technique come forward to do the
technique he comes forward to do the I
can just
move my being locked into the inertial
energy of the forward progress is what
provides angles of cancellation that
won't let me counter the throw okay so
whenever you're throwing someone
backwards it has to be going forward
okay so I brought him forward he's going
forward now I got to figure out to as I
after I generated his forward energy
now I got to figure out how to turn it
so that that forward energy is now going
backwards to provide the yin energy or
the yin opening for me to enter like the
technique requires and that is going to
be
done
in this fashion so if you watch the
technique I am bringing him into this
adhesion point and transition it to this
adhesion point so I going from here and
now I don't care about his grip I'm here
on his face okay anywhere on his head
face area was my sole
intention when I brought him forward and
you will use your footwork to make that
happen that's what I
want pass it from this adhesion point to
this adhesion point I want you to be
conscious of it
now I not knocking
him I'm just touching it there so when
he hits that new adhesion point I have
to match his y value so I get the
adhesion knocking him is is not going to
do
it so our little micr drill is get on
that adhesion
Point okay let's
go so what you did with the initial hand
workk to bring him forward is a yes it
is a Yin
yield
but it's not me getting out of the way
is it I have an Ike adhesion at the
grip and a
seizure at the tanden that's what moves
him forward
okay and now what I do at the grip so
this is at this is at the
grip and this is at at the tanden the
lower
tanden and then what I ended up
doing was I took this and went not at
the grip but at the middle portion of
the heaven arm okay so we're going to do
middle of the heaven
arm that's where I move my adhesion
to and and I keep the
seizure at the lower T end that's where
I am in this technique so far
okay now what I'm going to do is another
Yin yield at this
point it is going to be still an
adhesion and a
seizure I'm not just getting out of the
way I am moving this person's
midsection okay I'm going to do this at
the middle Heaven
arm and what I'm doing here is just two
dimensionally to keep it simple is
energy was going
forward this
way and what I'm going to do is slightly
turn
it it's still going with its initial
energy forward
you guys got
it okay what I am not going to
do is a Yong Yong Clash what a Yong Yong
Clash does is Energy's going
forward and then I try to shove it
backwards and make it go this way I'm
not going to do that so let this turn
right here is your Yin
yield and this y that Yin yield where
you take penetrating energy keep it
going with its initial inertial
trajectory in terms of within itself but
now going in a different
direction okay that is what you do all
the time in iido so for
example uh y
okay I'm going to do
um Ed nugget and a lot of people see
this kind of
stuff but his energy is going forward
and what I'm going to do is adhere and
start to bring it around this way as far
as his center line goes it's still going
forward of the center line but instead
of East he's now headed west okay or we
have a c
hole you get this adhesion now on the
outer side of my arm and his energy was
going east I'm going to keep it going
forward it's now going that way west
okay with that little
turn that's what you're doing here as
well so you're bringing him forward he's
there stay there like in that
position it's at this point that I keep
him going forward in a little turn of
like de net let's go back in that
position or with a little turn I pke you
hold I'm now doing it here with the
middle part of the
arm bring him forward to there
W turn his chin turn his head
that way if you pay attention his Center
keeps going
forward he touches turn
it all right let's try it all
right in all key
Ona you have this thing that I have
called in English spiral
rotate it's an extension of Yin Yong
Theory so if you have Yin and yangong
and you you give one the horizontal axis
and one the vertical axis they are at
their sharpest distinction they are at
their fullest yinin Yong okay and you go
back to yinong Theory and and uh prior
to them reaching such a dichotomous
nature there was something that was pre-
dichotomy we don't have a name for it we
call it the doubt
okay in this alchemical Theory as it is
applied to the technique and to your
body and to your spirit what you're
going to try to do is take that sharp
distinction between Yin and yangong and
undo it and you return to the Dow to the
nameless State okay the way you undo
that is get rid of this solid concrete
plus sign and how do you do that you're
going to start this cross
spinning do more than that though make
it rotate too and make it spiral through
space and now Yin and yangong
technically is being
undone got
it so energetic Al that's what you're
trying to
do you're trying to do that of course
with nagas tonden so yes there's an
external component to it but you're
trying to do it internally with your
tonden when you're able to do that let's
make a jump but I wouldn't consider this
part of kihon waza
101 when you're able to do that within
your own tonden you will be able to do
it into ukis tanden and when you're able
to do it within your tanden and ukas
tanden you will reach an energetic value
for that will manifest at the level of
the heart mind at level of shin the
level of cocol okay and that's a
Reconciliation between the ego
tripartite mind and the god mind it puts
you in that ecstatic state so every time
you're doing kihon waza and you do this
you're getting in that ecstatic State
you returning to that pre Yin and
yangong that pre dichotomy okay okay
that is
misogi so if we look here at this
technique 's energy is going this
way okay and I am going to make it go
the other way and of course here we're
looking just two-dimensionally as you
would feel is zuk get there's some down
and there's some lift as well in all of
these patterns okay and that's why it's
spiral rotating it's not just turning on
a flat surface okay eventually I'm going
to make UK go this way right UK energy
as far as their inertia in their body
they're still going in the same
direction okay and I'm going to make one
more turn to complete completely undo
these cross pattern here got it you have
to do this at the
end and then this this is really my
upper body on my lower body it's going
to go this way and
turn okay now if you look closely you
got like one Loop here and another loop
here I'm we pull those two Loops out and
you kind of have your little Infinity
thing doing that's what you're trying to
do here
okay and then uh when you're if if you
extend this one around this way you have
it again over here do you see it so you
have one horizontal one and
one vertical one your spiral rotating
the whole technique okay what is key
though for this throw is this trajectory
here it is very common for the beginner
to make their legs their lower part of
their body m match perfectly the upper
part of the body and that messes you up
okay so I'll show you what I mean all
right so it's in your
Ed
here there the other turn is when you
turn the qua into the throat which is
why you would never do it like
this but that line across is
the
now let's
look let's look at this part so that
need me was this line This
rotation is when I turn my
cloth this part
here we're looking at this
part
and this is where I think you're running
into problems and Margaret you're
running into problems when you are
imagining this technique you're
imagining a guy going here and then he
bends over and then he he falls
backward again he's coming forward you
bend him at his waist and he comes
backwards okay
this bending at his
waist that
part that is not good that's wrong if I
seized his tongue de he can't bend at
his waist do he can't he gets rigid okay
so now what I would like for you to do
is watch his body in the throw to see if
he hinges at his weight got it okay you
can watch for him
what did you say no I was to to contrast
it uh go ahead and hinge backwards there
you see
that that's different totally different
okay if he can hinge at his waist then
he does not need to come forward
he has control over his body okay so uh
he'll come forward hinge at his waist
and then I'll
throw here I when I try to throw you
backwards just walk out hinge walk
out let's do better than that use your
athleticism Bend backwards hinge
back
okay same thing try it
again no choice got it so he's not he
he's not taking ukmi in the Contemporary
sense where he positions himself and
goes and gives me the
choreography he's being thrown there's
no choice he has no choice do you see
that his
Emi is very
simplified finally display
and then don't die cuz I'm going to
throw you so don't hit your head on the
M get it got it okay let's try those two
things in what you're doing go so
because his body is going to be
rigid what I'm going to do is spiral
rotate him so he's going to come in he's
going to tilt this thing's going to go
around I start to bring it this
way so you have your cross and basically
he's doing that these movements and
doing that with his body and he goes
around he goes out the other side in he
goes I tilt him and bring him around the
other side you're doing these
things okay so if you pay
attention I don't try to bend him I
don't try to hook his head he's going to
get this tilt and then that that tilt I
make go around
me because I'm getting in here so let's
maybe see it from back
here I'm not trying to bend
him I just get a little tilt out of his
body that's enough I yield it and
SP
don't try to bend him don't try to bend
him that's not it tilt him spiral
him tilt
him okay let's go